by the way so there was something that i
meant to
mention earlier if you don't mind going
back which is this when we were talking
about bci
um so i don't know if you know this but
what i'm spending 90 of my time doing
now is running a company
do you know about this yes i i wasn't
sure what the company
is involved in right so talk about it
yeah yeah
so when it comes to the future of bci um
you know you can put stuff into the
brain
invasively but my interest has been
how you can get data streams into the
brain non-invasively so i run a company
called neosensory
and uh what we build is this little um
wristband we've built this in many
different
wow factors that's it yeah this is it
and it's got these vibratory motors in
it
so these things as i'm speaking for
example it's
you know capturing my voice and running
algorithms and then turning that into
patterns of vibration here
so people who are deaf for example
learn to hear through their skin so the
information is getting up to their brain
this way
and they learn how to hear so it turns
out on day one
people are pretty good like better than
you would expect at being able to say
oh that's weird it was that was that a
dog barking was that a baby crying was
that a door knock a doorbell
like people are pretty good at it but
with time they get better and better
and what it becomes is a new qualia in
other words a new
subjective internal experience so on day
one they they say
whoa what was that oh oh that was the
dog barking
but by you know three months later they
say oh there's dog barking somewhere oh
there's the dog
that's fascinating and by the way that's
exactly how you learn how to use your
ears
so what you of course need to remember
this but when you're an infant all you
have
are you know your eardrum vibrating
causes spikes to go down
your auditory nerves and impinging your
you know auditory cortex
your brain doesn't know what those mean
automatically but what happens is you
learn how to hear by looking for
correlations you know you clap your
hands
as a baby you know you look at your
mother's mouth moving and
and that correlates with what's going on
there and eventually your brain says
sorry i'm just going to summarize this
as
an internal experience as a conscious
experience and that's exactly what
happens here
the weird part is that you can feed data
into the brain not through the ears but
through any channel that gets there as
long as the information gets there your
brain figures out what to do with it
that's fascinating
like expanding the set of sensors
it could be could be arbitrarily uh
could it could yeah could expand
arbitrarily which is fascinating well
exactly and by the way
the reason i use this skin you know
there's all kinds of cool stuff going on
in the ar world's glasses
but the fact is your eyes are overtaxed
and your ears are overtaxed and you need
to be able to see and hear other stuff
but you're covered with the skin which
is this incredible computational
material
with which you can feed information and
we don't use our skin for much of
anything nowadays
um my joke in the lab is that i say we
don't call this the waste for nothing
because originally we built this the
vest and you know you're passing in all
this information
um that way and um
what i'm doing here with with the deaf
community
is is what's called sensory substitution
where i'm capturing
sound and scent you know i'm just
replacing the ears with the skin
and that works um one of the things i
talk about in livewire is
sensory expansion so what if you took
something like your
your visual system which picks up on a
very thin slice of the electromagnetic
spectrum
and you could see infrared or
ultraviolet so we've hooked that up
infrared and ultraviolet detectors and
you know i can feel what's going on so
just as an example the first night i
built the
infrared one of my engineers built that
the infrared detector i was
walking in the dark between two houses
and suddenly i felt all this infrared
radiation i was like where's that coming
from
and i just followed my wrist and i found
a um an infrared camera a night vision
camera
that was but like you know i immediately
oh there there's that thing there
but of course i would have never seen it
but now it's just part of my
reality that's fascinating yeah and then
of course what i'm really interested in
is sensory
addition what if you could pick up on
stuff that
isn't even part of what we normally pick
up on like you know like the magnetic
field of the earth or
twitter or stock market or things like
that or the i don't know some weird
stuff like the moods of other people or
something like that sure
now what you need is a way to measure
measure so as long as there's a machine
that can measure it it's easy it's
trivial to feed this in here and you
come to be
it comes to be part of your reality it's
like you have another sensor
and that that kind of thing is without
doing like if you look in your link
without
i forgot how you put it but it was
eloquent you know without getting
cutting into the brain basically yeah
exactly exactly so this
this costs at the moment 399 dollars
that's not going to kill you
and yeah it's not going to kill you it's
you just put it on and when you're done
you take it off
yeah um yeah and so uh and the name of
the company by the way is neo sensory
for new senses because the whole idea is
beautiful you can as i said you know you
come to the table with certain plug and
play devices and then that's it like i
can pick up on this little bit of the
electromagnetic radiation you can pick
up on
on this little frequency band uh for
hearing and so on
but but but i'm stuck there and there's
no reason we have to be stuck there we
can expand our oomvelt
by adding new senses yeah what's um oh
i'm sorry the umvelt
is the slice of reality that you pick up
on so each animal has its own
hell of a ward umvelt yeah exactly
so i'm sorry i forgot to define it
before it's it's it's such an important
concept which is to say
um for example if you are a a tick
you pick up on uh butyric acid you pick
up on odor and you pick up on
temperature that's it
that's how you construct your reality is
with those two sensors if you are a
blind echolocating bat you're picking up
on
air compression waves coming back you
know echo location if you are
the black ghost knife fish you're
picking up on changes in the
electrical field around you with electro
reception that's how they swim around
and tell there's a rock there and so on
but but that's that's all they pick up
on that's their umvelt
it's that's their the signals they get
from the world from which to construct
their reality and they can be totally
different ooh belts
and so our human umvelt is
you know we've got little bits that we
can pick up on one of the things i like
to do with my students is talk about
um imagine that you are a bloodhound dog
right you are a blonde how dog with a
huge snout with 200 million
receptors in it and your whole world is
about smelling
you know you've got slits in your
nostrils like big nose full of air and
so on
do you have a dog do you no you used to
use it okay so you know you walk your
dog around and your dog is smelling
everything
the whole world is full of signals that
you do not pick up on it so imagine if
you were that dog and you looked at your
human master and thought my god what is
it like to have the pitiful little nose
of a human yeah
how could you not know that there's a
cat 100 yards away or that your friend
was here six hours ago
and so the idea is because we're stuck
in our oom belt because we have this
little pitiful noses we think
okay well yeah we're seeing reality but
but you can have very different sorts of
realities depending on the
peripheral plug and play devices you're
equipped with it's fascinating to think
that like
if we're being honest probably our own
belt is
uh you know some infinitely tiny
percent of the possibilities of how you
can sense
quote unquote reality even if you could
i mean there's a guy named don uh
donald uh hoffman yeah who basically
basically says uh we're really far away
from reality
in terms of our ability to sense
anything like we
we're very we're almost like we're
floating out there
that's almost like completely attached
to the actual physical reality
it's fascinating that we could have
extra senses that
could help us get a little bit a little
bit closer exactly and by the way this
has been the
the fruits of science is realizing like
for example you know you open your eyes
and there's the world around you right
but
of course depending on how you calculate
it it's less than a 10 trillion
of the electromagnetic spectrum that we
call visible light
uh the reason i say it depends because
you know it's actually infinite in all
directions
yeah and so that's exactly that and then
science allows you to
actually look into the rest of it
exactly sort of understanding how big
the world is out there and the same with
the the world of really small in the
world of really large
exactly that's beyond our ability to
sense exactly and so the reason i think
this kind of thing matters is because we
now have an opportunity
for that first time in human history to
say
okay well i'm just going to include
other things in my umvelt so i'm going
to include infrared radiation
and and have a direct perceptual
experience of that
and so i'm very you know i mean so you
know i've given up my lab and i run this
company 90
of my time now that's what i'm doing i
still teach at stanford and i'm you know
teaching courses and
stuff like that but this is like a this
is your your passion
the fire is as on this yeah i feel like
this is
the most important thing that's
happening right now i mean
obviously i think that because that's
what i'm devoting my time and my life to
but
um i mean it's a brilliant set of ideas
it certainly is like
it um it's a step in uh in a very
vibrant future i would say like that the
possibilities there
are are endless exactly so if you ask
what i think about neural link
i think it's amazing what those guys are
doing and working on but i think it's
not practical for almost everybody for
example for people who are deaf they buy
this
and you know every day we're getting
tons of emails and tweets or whatever
from people saying wow i picked up on
this and then i had no idea that was a
i didn't even know that was happening
out there yeah and they're coming to
here
dude by the way this is you know less
than a tenth of the price of a hearing
aid and
like 250 times less than a cochlear
implant
you